part b
write the first four write the first
four non-zero terms of the maclaurin
series for f prime the derivative of f
express f prime as a rational function
for the absolute value of x being less
than
r our radius of convergence
so if we want to find f prime we could
just take each of we could just take the
derivative of each of these terms with
respect to x
and so we could just say
if this is f then f prime and i'm not
going to scroll down just so i can see
this up here we could just say f prime
f prime of x
is going to be or the maclaurin series
for f prime of x maybe i should write it
that way
so let me write it this way
maclaurin
mclaurin
mclaren that a looked funny
maclaurin
series
for
f prime
f prime of x
well it's going to be the sum
from n equals 1
to infinity
and we would just take the derivative of
this right over here with respect to x
and so this is just a application of the
power rule take the exponent right over
here multiply it by the coefficient so
if you take n times this that cancels
out with this n so it's going to be
negative 3
to the n minus 1 and then decrement your
exponent times x
to the n minus 1. and so they want us to
write the first four non-zero terms of
the maclaurin series
so that is going to be equal to so i'll
write approximately equal to because
we're only going to write the first four
of terms of this infinite series and
just to be clear what i did i just did
the power rule here i looked at this
exponent which is n multiplied by this
coefficient which had an n in the
denominator so that n and the this n
cancel out so i'm just left with
negative 3 to the n minus 1 and then i
decrement that exponent that's straight
out of the power rule one of the first
things you learned about taking
derivatives and so if we want the first
four non-zero terms when n equals one
this is going to be negative three to
the one minus one power let me just
write it negative three to the one minus
one
times x to the one minus one that's when
n equals one
plus
negative three
negative three to the two minus one
two minus one times x to the two minus
one
and then and actually i could well i
could have just written this as negative
3x to the n minus 1. actually let me let
me do that just for
so this is
this i could just write because they
have the same exponent this will
simplify a little bit as
negative 3x
to the n minus 1. and so this is going
to be approximately
when n is equal to 1 this is going to be
equal to 0 so negative 3x to the 0 power
is just going to be 1.
when n is equal to
when n is equal to 2
this is going to be 2 minus 1. so it's
going to be the first power so negative
3x to the first power so i could just
write this as
negative 3x and then when n is 3 well
this is going to be negative 3x squared
so negative 3x squared is going to be
negative 3 squared is 9
x squared
and then the fourth term is going to be
negative 3x to the 4 minus 1 power so to
the third power so negative 3 to the
third power is negative 27
times x to the third power so there you
have it that's the first four non-zero
terms of the maclaurin series you could
have also just looked over here and said
okay the derivative of x
is with respect to x is one derivative
of negative three halves x squared with
respect to x
is negative 3 you could have said the
derivative of this is 9x squared right
over there and then you would have had
to write out the fourth term and take
out the derivative in the same way and
you would have gotten this right over
here so we did the first part we wrote
the first four non-zero terms of the
maclaurin series for f prime the
derivative of f and then they say
express f prime is a rational function
for the absolute value of x being less
than r
so this sum
this sum if we assume it converges and
we know the radius of convergence
already
so
or assuming that we're dealing with x
that are within the radius of
convergence
so this right over here you might
recognize this so i could write it like
that or i could also write it i could
also write it if i take if i start at n
equals 0
so i could also write this as from n
equals 1 to infinity of or actually from
n equals
to infinity of
negative 3 x
to the n minus 1. either or sorry to the
n
because now the first term is to the 0th
power that first term was the 0 power so
whether you do 1 minus 1 is where you
start or you just start at zero these
two things are equivalent you might
recognize these as a geometric series
with common ratio of
negative of negative three x and so
what's the sum of a geometric series
with common ratio with a certain common
ratio well it's going to be equal to the
first term and regardless of how you
view this the first term is going to be
divided by 1 minus the common ratio so
our common ratio is negative 3x 1 minus
negative 3x well that's just going to be
1 plus 3x
if what i just did here looks unfamiliar
to you i encourage you to watch the sum
of infinite geometric series and not
only do we show you this formula and how
to apply it but we show how you can
prove this formula it's actually a
pretty fun proof but anyway regardless
of how you view this maclaurin series it
is an infinite geometric series and this
assuming that our x is in our radius of
convergence this is what our sum is this
is what we are going to converge to